[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission au sein de sa
découvre la réunion sans aller parer
alors allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune de Saint-Luc plus
précisément à la chaloupe Saint-Louis
allez allons à ça
pas mal de chevaux bonjour madame oui
bonjour Comment allez les Lamentin de
préparer les chevaux pour nous partirons
une petite balade
jusqu'à quel âge
bonne question bon à partir de 6 ans
nous on a des enfants ils montrent des
bruits très bien les baptêmes s'il y a
pas de cette 4 ans 3 ans et demi quatre
ans et jusqu'à quel âge dernièrement
j'ai mis ma tatie qu'elle avait 70 ans à
monter voilà
tout le monde en l'air d'accord
aujourd'hui que il mange enfin il nous a
fait la balade nous mange la
positivement tranquillement chez eux
l'après-midi il n'est pas poussé hein
c'est vraiment à cool
pique-nique à la ferme
[Musique]
la balade à cheval
comme en France
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour on va y aller
est-ce que le premier fois non non
c'est vrai ouais
puis voilà et quelles sensations on
trouve qu'on fait ça
pur on va dire c'est vrai oui et qui ça
l'a fait découvrir ou le cheval ou mais
c'est avec ma fille en fait on a fait
une balade une fois
donc on est parti voilà comme ça on
range ça va quoi pour combien de temps
là pour la journée ça pour la journée
passe une bonne journée oui
à cheval et un moment donné à pied
ok il est juste en bas ça
du jardin d'accord ouais ben écoute
[Musique]
ben voilà balade à cheval ce matin tu es
vraiment agréable et maintenant le sa
découvre le jardin botanique mascara
bonjour madame bonjour monsieur comment
allez-vous bien bien merci alors dis-moi
je vois vous descendez moi je monte vous
avez fini vos visite j'ai terminé ma
visite je suis venue déjà plusieurs fois
sur le jardin c'est vrai parce que c'est
un vrai bonheur aussi bien pour les
fleurs que pour les oiseaux d'accord et
voilà c'est vraiment un havre de paix je
viens de à la Réunion régulièrement pour
mon travail d'accord et je m'accorde
toujours un petit moment de détente sur
ce jardin des mascara qui est vraiment
superbe j'ai visité la maison bien sûr
parce que ça c'est toujours agréable de
pouvoir
retrouver dans l'habitat ça fait rêver
sur l'histoire de l'île et qui c'est qui
vous avez parlé de ce domaine là vous il
est très bien côté sur les guides
touristiques donc ça fait partie pour
moi des incontournables moi je vais
faire la visite merci Madame bonne
visite
au revoir
[Musique]
les vraiment joli et les Gaïa et bien
même savoir
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment
allez-vous
un jardin là mascara c'est plusieurs
choses en même temps c'est un site
historique comme on l'a vu c'est une
vieille un vieux domaine que n'a plus de
200 ans avec l'histoire la famille du
château vieux tout le tout le domaine
agricole nous on a encore des vieilles
étables des écuries une forge etc donc
c'est vraiment un patrimoine historique
qui appartient au conseil départemental
d'accord et on a aussi donc nous
valorise ce patrimoine vous êtes aussi
valoriser le patrimoine végétal de la
Réunion quoi les espèces endémiques mais
aussi pour avoir des fruitiers ou pour
avoir des cactus ou pour avoir
des palmiers nous on a des orchidées
Nuna une collection récente là sur les
plantes carnivores ça a été bien bonne
Marmagne avec des expositions avec les
[Musique]
la réunion nous les larmes mon pays
comment il est la réunion s'amène
et ben voilà les petites découvertes
étaient vraiment Gaya ce matin à cheval
il ne l'a fini par le jardin botanique
mascara avec Gaïa
a longtemps visites et pour ça on vous a
prochain épisode de l'émission loulou
cette fois-ci sera dans le siècle
derrière la semaine la trouve
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]